[Applaudissements]
ça va mais les becs
mais bertrand nommé saga tout coup
agathon trou non je crois que vous
l'avez dit choqué sur balance la sauce
ou chez pac walhalla votre nouvelle
émission norma je vous ne connaissez pas
vous ne connaissez pas oui vous êtes qui
je suis sophie de terre at sauf hilter
suis agrafeuse influent seul chômeuse
quoi 623 fawer france annabi louche en a
combien toi tu as comme un taux de
followers 3 millions de semis perds tu
veux une médaille c'est pas bref ma
peine sauf fin d'ailleurs mes amis
disent souvent ah tiens je suis passé
chez sauf j'ai oublié de vous préciser
nabil où je dois savoir de quoi je parle
cette souris est sponsorisé par des mars
c'est beaucoup sur les réseaux je fais
du placement de produits est fou de joie
raconte un truc je suis en train de
vivre une expérience paranormale l'acea
au delà de nos différences
[Musique]
excusez moi c'est l'assistant vocal
farce musique c'est la john à régis
schultz pas merci donc bref ça leur
jurant de los angeles de l est j'allume
la télé est hélas ma d-box émotions ma
box est bloqué sur la s'est vite
impossible de retrouver ma télécommande
passer des etats-unis à bouna c'est
choquant c'est comme passer je sais pas
moi du coca light
bref tout ça pour dire que je suis je
suis comment vous dites déjà en rascasse
voilà jorasses casque c'est la grande
rascasse mais à bouna une question dans
l'émission vous vous parlez de quoi au
juste
je veux tu as télé de la télé sinon vous
vous parlez d'actu genre nabila donne
son point de vue sur la démission du
ministre de l'ecologie assuré valérie
van mello quoi et à bouna
non je vous aime beaucoup mais à bouna
les fringues a le look on en parle
non mais cette veste cette baisse a
bouna gérer une casse automobile
vous organisez des combats de coqs
clandestins se séparent et sérieuse
c'est ce que c'est que ça c'est
magnifique alors c'est mon nouveau look
mais j'aime bien j'aime bien on va vers
le nord on adore en revanche je suis
ravi mais leur ravir a dit que vous
receviez stéphane plaza immobilier bon
soyons dignes et j'adore aller bien
ça va simple et beau j'ai vu le petit
cul cul tout à l'heure c'est pas les
femmes à l'époque parce qu'on voit tout
à l'heure par rapport au petit t2
rooftops double vasque dans le marais
dont vous m'avez parlé bien sûr allez
c'est pas tout on va passer à la météo
quand même j'ai réagi aux intérêts de
votre groupe à et bien je vous dis tout
de suite envoyé les marchés où tu te
calmes non mais ça va me regarder demain
matin la france se met un petit marcel
gris le garder en club c'est un croc top
on voit les vendre il a les températures
alors 17 degrés dans le troisième à
paris 17 dans le 11e et 17 dans le 17
l'après-midi la france on se fait mutine
elle enlève une manche célibattante open
aura 21 ans à limoges 28 à calvi on the
rocks et 19 à angoisse je ne parle pas
de ma prestation bien sûr de cette ville
qui se situe en dordogne demain 6
septembre ce sera la saint bertrand ça
va pas trop changé c'est tous les jours
ça fait depuis lundi à l'est